i ran into chuck schumer today in
brooklyn
and he had on a mask that said cancel
student debt
which i appreciated a great deal from
the majority leader
i know there's been some discussion as
to whether joe has the ability to cancel
student debt via executive order and
then some people have gone back and
forth
i'm going to go on the record and say if
i were president i would certainly be
testing my ability to do that
that's like let's see if we can do it do
you have a point of view
both on the ability to cancel student
debt and then the
wisdom of doing so it's it's hard to say
like i
i i listen to lawyers who
know this area of the law really well
and they make very persuasive
arguments and in a world where i thought
the way things worked was that if you
had sound legal arguments for something
you got to do it
um you know i'd say yes he absolutely
can do it and it's just a matter of
making sure that he follows the
administrative procedures act or
whatever he has to do to uh to make it
lawful
uh when when done but in the world we
actually live in the question of whether
he can do it or not is going to be
answered
perhaps by a very skewed supreme court
and i have no idea what they're going to
say um oh
no oh no this new supreme court because
the court is not
like a natural ally of the biden
administration
uh what do you do about that well one
argument is you got to move fast because
you're very likely to run into legal
issues with
the supreme court and have to take a
second bite at things or whatever
uh the the the flip side of that is that
if you move too fast and you don't
dot all your eyes and cross your t's
then the work you do might end up
getting thrown out on some sort of legal
technicality as opposed to
the substance of the law so i think that
that probably explains
part of why um you know we're going to
probably
cross the 100-day threshold and and he
won't have
uh forgiven any student debt um
but uh there are other considerations
too um
i think that you know in an environment
where you have just passed a two
trillion dollar coronavirus relief bill
and you want to pass another very large
bill that won't be fully
financed um if you're going to
play ftse with with inflation maybe you
want to
see what happens with those before you
write off another several hundred
billion dollars
in student debt um and that may be part
of the reason why they're not
racing to do this i think there's a
there's a there's a third
uh issue to consider which is if you're
going to do something like that which
pulls pretty well
will definitely make a lot of your own
voters enthusiastic likely to show up at
the polls
do you maybe want to try to do it closer
to an election
i think that all of those factors are
probably contributing to
the internal debate uh at the in the
biden administration over what to do
when to do it how big to go that's
fascinating
you're right that it would be hundreds
of billions of dollars if it was going
to be significant at all i think the
level of
education uh debt out there right now is
1.6
trillion last night i'm operating from
memory here but i think that you know
the
the smaller relief uh idea that that
biden has embraced at ten thousand
dollars
worth of student debt and and uh phase
out um
is somewhere in the 300 billion dollar
range and the
and the schumer uh warren plan to uh
sort of fifty thousand dollars just
forgive as much debt as you can is about
a trillion
so it's a lot of money um it's not if
it would have been a no-brainer i think
in an environment where mitch mcconnell
was running the senate and had said no
to the american rescue plan
well then you need to get money out the
door and that's a that's a freebie um
just do it some students right now are
wincing at this
i know well that's the thing is that for
all for all these uh
any kind of stimulus like the nice thing
about the rescue plan is that it was
very broad-based like it's a few people
relatively speaking myself yourself
perhaps who got like no have gotten no
covert relief over the last
year uh we're like in the small minority
of people who don't qualify
and basically everyone else gets a
stimulus check many people get
get unemployment etc etc the student
loan
plan is comparably much more targeted
and so when when you stop talking about
aggregates
huge sums of money being distributed
broadly and start talking about
individual programs and you say well
because we did this one thing now maybe
we have to take a pause on the other
thing
well then the constituency that would
benefit from that is like well i was
told that i was going to get my student
loan for give
when's that going to happen but you know
a promise is a promise i expect it's
coming i don't think he's going to
renege
well that that's great news uh to a lot
of people
and one of the things i did suggest
which the american rescue plan act does
address in in large part is that you
want to get money out very broadly like
you don't want to pick a certain segment
of the population
and say we're going to help you and not
necessarily get help to others
so what is your prognosis for the
infrastructure bill what are we looking
at
uh brian you know because there's so
many people that want a lot of things in
there
and let me also say on the record i love
it all like just about everything i've
seen i'm like sure
throw it in there um
so what what are you seeing and hearing
in terms of
um it could be at this point individual
legislators and like their pet issues
like what they will and won't
accept uh the ultimate size of the bill
i've seen something in like the
two trillion dollar range i i believe
uh is this also going to be a bill that
gets no republicans i get the sense that
it probably will be from
what i'm hearing look in a world
where uh the filibuster were to be
abolished or reformed
if democrats were to do that before
reaching
uh the jobs plan you could you could
imagine a world where
you break that bill up into different
pieces and some republicans maybe
a handful of them support this piece but
not that piece but mostly democrats pass
the whole thing in piecemeal um but
because
the rules of the senate are what they
are and it seems like
question whether they're going to
abolish or reform the filibusters now
kind of in doubt
you have to do it as one giant package
and put it through the budget process
so that you can circumvent the
filibuster so that makes it hard you
have to hold
all 50 senators together all like make
sure that
nobody's uh like ideas that they care
deeply about are
omitted also not at ideas that are
viewed as sort of poison pills to uh you
know joe manchin on the one end or
bernie sanders on the other
um you have to uh find a method of
paying for it that isn't pay you know
raising taxes too aggressively
or or to or not paying for enough of it
and not because
there's necessarily a right answer to
that question but because you need all
50
uh members to agree and that's a hard
thing to do part of me thinks it's sort
of like
too big to fail in some sense like i
don't think democrats want to go
into the midterms having dealt joe biden
a very big defeat
because he's basically said this is what
we need to do and
like he's put his whole administration
behind it and
um you know that gives me uh like some
hope that
that it'll pass but for that to happen i
think
democrats have to embrace
that feeling this the sort of psychology
that they had
after the rescue plan passed right where
they didn't let their
peccadillos uh eat away at the bill
until it
fell apart or got you know became too
small there wasn't a lot of rancor that
bill passed and everyone was happy and
everyone thought they did a good thing
um and everyone felt proud that they can
kind of repeat that process
where they say you know there will be a
time to fight for my pet project
on future bills but for this bill what
we need to do
is limit the amount of rancor in within
our own ranks
um and we also uh we also need to move
quickly
and uh and we we need to you know
satisfy ourselves with
very small trims around the edges as
opposed to big changes
um then they can just do it and it'll
pass they'll feel good about it again uh
and then they can
uh resume squabbling over you know
the more trivial issues that divide them
um
the risk is that you know there's no
there's no deadline to pass this bill
there's no
this this bill will seemingly have a tax
component so it's just
harder to get that kind of agreement to
get people to agree
to set aside their uh their priorities
and just trust that joe biden's plan is
the
is the right plan um and i think it sort
of remains to be seen whether they can
do that it'll be a big feat if they do
and
uh it'll be a big legacy uh piece for
biden but also for chuck schumer in a
way
my advice to democratic legislators is
get addicted to victory you know that
feeling you had
that win you were like we're helping
hundreds of millions of people
everyone's gonna love us people are
going to get those 1400
checks people are going to get this
child tax credit like we're going to be
heroes
just get addicted to that just be like
that is not enough
yeah i i write a newsletter once a week
and uh
this was writing about this exact topic
and i
i compared the advice i had for them to
the advice that you get from like
the worst baseball coach in little
league who like watches
you hit a home run and it's just like do
that again do that again like do that
again
that is useless in baseball but i think
i
i think you know legislating is actually
a very complicated thing but
given the limitations that democrats
have they have 50 votes everyone needs
to be on board so everyone is
potentially a king maker
anyone could spoil this thing so
basically everyone has to agree not to
do that
once you get that kind of consensus that
we have to just move
uh then i think it's possible and it's
not a model of legislating that i think
you'll see repeated a lot in history if
they do it um
you know legislation tends to the
acrimonious but um
uh but i think it's you know it is
possible because what you say like the
the rescue plan was a huge win
uh they feel good about it so why not
repeat the process
i find myself cautiously optimistic
somehow because
we do we need to do a lot more uh and
the biden administration frankly rests
on being able to get
a significant infrastructure bill passed
uh
when i spoke to joe not that long ago
he literally said to me we need to
rebuild the country and this is the
the bill to do that he met literally too
it's like we literally
need to rebuild the country
[Music]
you